les deux diplomates devront rencontrer
dans la journée le président ukrainien
volodimir zelensky principal objectif de
cette rencontre et bien réaffirmer le
soutien de l'union européenne à
l'ukraine on en parle avec vos bruno
daroux merci de nous avoir rejoints en
plateau cette visite elle est avant tout
symbolique mais les images ont un impact
tout de même assez fort puisque quelques
jours à peine après ce massacre ursula
von der leyen et josep borrell seront
donc à abuja oui on s'est passé les
massacres ont tous eu lieu il ya une
semaine mais en tout cas ça a été
découvert effectivement il ya une
dizaine de jours et
effectivement les l'image est très forte
de la hyène et josep borrell donc la
président de la commission européenne
est en quelque sorte le ministre des
affaires étrangères de l'union
européenne sur place sur les lieux du
crime en quelque sorte marquer
évidemment leur leur effroi se
recueillir la finale a eu quelques mots
évidemment en disant que ici de
l'humanité avait été tout simplement
oublié danser dans ces actes barbares
donc effectivement là les images sont
très fortes ça veut dire que celle qui
représente l'ensemble des 27 pays
européens hélas à bouchain pour
condamner ce qui ce qui a été fait au
delà de ce déplacement effectivement
hautement symbolique il va y avoir cette
rencontre aussi avec le président
zelensky et cela von der leyen va
marquer physiquement le soutien de
l'europe au président ukrainien ça veut
dire aussi que pour l'europe le cren
continue à être un état qui existe qui
fonctionne qui a une activité
diplomatique et c'est important de le
dire est que les dirigeants n'hésitent
pas à venir à kiev et puis elle va
également
détaillé les nouvelles sanctions qui ont
été décidées contre moscou annoncée
aussi très certainement 500 millions
d'euros dead supplémentaires pour aider
l'ukraine à se réarmer appuyé fortement
également la candidature de l'ukraine à
l'union européenne mais attention il ya
quand même un bémol à les présidents de
la commission européenne elle peut
proposer ça mais c'est le conseil
européen qui doit en décider les 27
chefs d'état et de gouvernement et là on
sait qu'il ya des désaccords on entre
certains dirigeants européens mais voyez
que l'ensemble de ces mesures annoncées
de cet engagement le fait même d'être
physiquement à kiev évidemment pour le
président ukrainien et sans doute pour
le peuple ukrainien c'est un signal de
réconfort et puis c'est un signal envoyé
aussi à vladimir ces images fortes ans
il faut il faut le dire celle de la
présidente de la commission européenne
habillé d'un gilet pare-balles 1 qui se
rend dans cette ville bocsa où 340 corps
de civils ont été retrouvés il ya un peu
plus d'une semaine